la russie de son côté enregistré un
nombre record des nouvelles infections
au coronavirus inquiétude également en
ce qui concerne le nombre de décès ont
fait le point avec 4 correspondant à
moscou antoine guillon près de trente
mille nouveaux cas ont été identifiés et
635 décès constatés ces dernières 24
heures sur l'ensemble du territoire
russe ce qui constitue un nouveau record
pour le pays
moscou reste le foyer le plus important
avec 8200 cinq nouvelles contaminations
cette dernière journée et c'est
probablement en régions où la situation
est la plus compliquée ainsi le
ministère de la défense a annoncé
l'envoi de deux unités médicales vers la
crimée afin de faire face à la pandémie
sur place contrairement à la plupart des
pays d'europe
il n'y a pas de confinement imposé en
russie unique mesure en plus des
gestes-barrières classiques que sont le
port du masque et des gants
la fermeture des bars et restaurants à
23h et cette hausse quotidienne du
nombre de cas ne montre pas de signe
d'affaiblissement
alors que pour voir une amélioration de
la situation il faudrait arriver à ce
point de bascule comme l'a évoqué
vladimir poutine notez les dîners mine
sous l'eau gelée et nos sectionné et une
période de travail conjoint encore plus
complexe et intense est encore à venir
nous devrons poursuivre la lutte contre
l'épidémie du coronavirus inverser le
cours des choses préserver une forte
mobilisation du système de santé
publique et de l'ensemble des services
sociaux de l'état est bien évidemment
tiré les leçons de tous les problèmes
auxquels nous avons fait face et auquel
nous nous sommes attaqués assurer la
reprise de l'emploi et une croissance
économique soutenue et le traitement
historique cheveux très tôt le roster
économique
bien entendu les autorités placent
beaucoup d'espoir dans la vaccination de
la population
mais même si celle ci a déjà commencé
depuis le 5 décembre
il faudra probablement attendre encore
plusieurs semaines dans les conditions
actuelles pour renverser la tendance